Today as a leader, a follower, a reader, a writer, a speaker, a listener,
a student, a teacher Jocko, Willink, welcome to the Rubin report.
How was that? I took that right out of the bio. That's good,
right out of the Twitter by as much word or viral. Yeah. Yeah.
You're a little bit of everything.
That actually is a pretty good explanation of you.
It actually, it actually is a pretty good explanation to me.
I think I cover those multiple dichotomies fairly well.
Yeah. That would probably explain why you've written roughly 37,000 books.
Right? How many, how many books have you written? I mean,
I normally only put one book on the table. We put four here.
So I've written so far. I've written three adult books and three kids books.
I've got another kid's book coming out in the spring and I've got another adult
book coming out,
going head to head with Jordan Peterson in January of 2020.
Oh, Oh yeah. I probably will be on tour with him for that book.
That means that we're going to be in competition. Okay. We'll bring it. Oh,
all right. We'll see. We'll see.
It's nice to, uh, to not actually have to compete with, with the officers. Yeah.
Yeah. Do you feel like you're in competition with anyone? That's,
that's an interesting place to start off.
Well, that's, I guess there's a dichotomy there too,
because I don't feel like I'm in competition with anyone.
And I feel like I'm in competition with everyone.
That's just sort of in my nature to just compete.
But no, I mean, in this world that I'm in right now,
I don't really feel like I'm competing with anyone.
I feel like I'm just kind of doing what I do talking about what I like to talk
about,
writing about what I like to write about and hanging out with cool people most
of the time. Yeah.
Pretty good. Pretty good. All right. Well,
I think 99% of my audience knows who you are and knows a lot about you,
but for the people that don't. And by the way,
I should say right before we started, I was saying,
we have been trying to coordinate this for about 27 years, right?
I mean a long time, which is kind of funny. I mean, it really says it's like,
well, we're two people that are,
that are busy and it was hard to hard to really make this happen.
But for the people that know nothing about you,
tell me a little bit about your history.
I was born and raised in a small new England town.
I was a rebellious kid, my
best way to rebel as a kid coming from a small new England town was to join the
military. So I joined the military after high school.
I spent 20 years in the military and when I retired from the military,
I started taking the things that I learned from the military and
teaching them to civilian companies and civilian leaders.
And eventually that turned into a book and a podcast and all this other stuff.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit more about what you were like that made you want to go
into the military. What was that rebellious kid or whatever that, yeah.
I just grew up in a,
in a little new England town and there was a lot of hippies and just
kind of kids like that running around and smoking pot and whatever.
And I really wasn't into that. And so, you know,
I think a lot of kids when they rebel as kids, because all kids rebel,
a lot of kids repelled by drinking,
or they do drugs or whatever they're going to do.
And I went in the other direction was like into hardcore music and
eventually said, Oh yeah,
I'm just going to join the military because that's what I'm going to do. Yeah.
It's funny.
When you talk about it, it almost sounds like you're slightly dismissing it,
but you had a, you had a pretty good storied career as a Navy seal.
Yeah, no, I grew up in the seal teams.
I went right in the Navy right in the seal teams and that's where I spent my,
my whole adult life.
And it was an incredible experience to work with a bunch of awesome people
and got to do things that I had dreamed about doing since I was a little kid.
Well,
what should we know about like the life of a Navy seal that you don't get in the
movies or, or however else we just sort of imagine these lives to be.
I would say the biggest thing to remember is that that people in the seal teams
and people in the military in general, they're people,
they're just normal people. They go home, they got wives, they got kids,
they're trying to live a normal life.
And then their job requires them to do things that are aren't very normal.
And so they, you know, for me,
I kind of learned to compartmentalize what I was doing in the military and when
I'd come home. And I always,
I tell this to police officers and firefighters and military guys today,
don't when you get home, don't bring your uniform home,
don't wear your uniform home. Like physically change your,
take your uniform off, leave it at work, put on your,
your civilian clothes and you go home and be a civilian.
How hard is that though? Once you're sort of in that locked mindset,
which obviously has so much to do with the things that you write about and why
your message actually is, is working and help.
And people you say, how hard is it? L it can be hard. It can be harsh. Uh,
you know, cause you've got one life that you're living where decisions are
really consequential.
And then you've got your regular life that you're living and things aren't
that they aren't as consequential. You know,
I had a situation where I was at work and there was a lot of stuff going on at
work. They were, they were redeploying people to Afghanistan.
There was big decisions that were being made at work.
And I remember I came home from work one day and like I said,
tried to try to leave my work at work,
but I'm sitting there thinking about how all this stuff is going to unfold.
And my wife, you know, I got home and my wife goes, Oh, I can't believe this.
And I was like, what happened is, is everything okay? And she says, you know,
the, no, it's not okay. The Disney on ice is the same night,
that's for the kids. And I'm just thinking, Hey, if that's,
if that's the biggest worries my wife has, then that's a positive thing.
Then life's pretty good. Yeah. Life's pretty good. Yeah.
So how quickly did you realize that you wanted to sort of bring these ideas
about personal responsibility and sort of owning your life and all that
into sort of that world, the world where Disney on ice matters?
Yeah, it's I was about six months from retiring.
I had a friend that was the CEO of a big company and he said,
I want you to come and talk to my executives about combat leadership.
And I said, Hey, sure sounds, it sounds cool. So I went and did it.
And when I got, and I don't think he really knew what to expect, you know,
because I'm looked like a knuckle dragger and uh, at least a good portion.
I actually am a knuckle dragger. And so we bring me in to talk and I thought,
I think he was maybe thinking, I tell some cooler stories and that'd be,
that'd be great. But I actually started talking about how you lead.
And when I got done, he came up to me and said,
I want you to do this for every division that I have in my company. And I said,
well, you know, I'm retiring. And he said, well, I'll give you money.
And I said, okay.
So I started working with all the different divisionals and at one of those
division meetings, the CEO of the parent company was there. And when I got done,
he came up to me and said,
I want you to come and talk to all my CEOs for all these companies that I want.
And he owned like 45 or 50 companies. So I went and did that.
And when I went and talked to those companies, of course,
then a bunch of those CEOs came up to me and said, Hey,
I want you to come and talk to my company. So that's kind of the,
the way that it started. And it didn't take me very long at all. I mean,
it actually was the very first company,
that first guy that I talked to when they started,
when that group started telling me about the problems they were having,
I was sitting there thinking to myself, well,
I saw these problems in seal platoons when I was training steel platoons.
It's the same thing. It's leadership. Yeah.
Were you surprised that the big successful businesses were having such a
leadership crisis?
I was surprised for about five minutes and then I realized that these are all
human beings.
These are the same human beings that are in a seal platoon in an army company
and in a business. And they're all,
they're all have the same idiosyncrasies that they have, the same egos,
the same personalities. You can see it all.
And when you've seen it all over and over again, it becomes pretty evident,
pretty clear when you're looking at it.
And the last job that I had in the seal teams, I was training.
I was running the seal training for the West coast seal teams.
And this isn't a trading room.
Where do you see like the guys carrying the boats on their heads and carrying
logs around and doing a bunch of pushups and stuff.
The training that I ran was the training where seals actually learn to go into
combat and fight the enemy.
And this is where we really start focusing on combat leadership.
And so in this training that I ran,
we got to take seal platoons and put them through really tough training
scenarios, very realistic training scenarios over and over and over again.
So every night I basically would be putting a new seal platoon through another
training scenario,
which the next night it would be another seal platoon going through this same
training scenario.
And then the next night I'd be another seal between going through the same
training center.
So you take these different seal pretends and what's different about a seal
platoon. What's different about a seal.
Platoon is really just boils down to the leadership because we've got 16 seals
in the ceiling. The guys are basically the same show. There's some,
there's a bell curve. There's some top end performers.
There's some low end performers is a bunch of guys in the middle.
So the real variation on their performance was based almost a hundred percent on
their, on their leadership. In fact,
it was a hundred percent on their leadership.
And so I got to see this and I to watch these leadership scenarios unfold over
and over again and see what leadership things worked and what didn't work. And,
and so by the time I, I left that job and entered the civilian sector,
I'd watch some random team of leaders inside of an organization.
And I'd say to myself, well, there's strategic messages.
And getting down to the frontline troops, they need to communicate this better.
Or, Oh, their departments aren't working together.
They need to cover move forward together. Or their mission is way too complex.
And that no one has any idea what they're actually supposed to be doing.
So they need to simplify this or that this senior leader is making all the
decisions and therefore everything's moving really slow and nothing's happening
at a good rate of speed. So they need to use decentralized manner.
And it was just so obvious when I start.
How much of leadership in general do you think is innate versus learned?
Obviously you're teaching people to learn part,
but there has to be some element that's an aid right.
There absolutely is. And there's the,
the analogy that I give and I don't play video games, but I've seen it.
But on video games, there's,
you have a character in a video game and you'll have a certain level of
intelligence and a certain level of strength and a certain level of agility.
And those levels are what you get.
And then you work with them while at the same thing for a leader.
And there's different.
There's different characteristics that you get that are good for leadership,
right? If you're someone that's really articulate,
that's a great thing to have to be a good leader because you want the human
beings that you're talking to to understand what you're actually saying. So,
and different people are naturally more articulate than other people.
It's good to be able to look at complex problems and be able to simplify them,
right? That's a,
that's a very powerful tool to have a really complex thing to solve and be able
to look at it and say, okay, simplify it. And then simplify it.
Not only for yourself, so you can decide what to do,
but simplify it for your team. So they understand what to do. That's,
that's a characteristic that some people have. The,
the one that I bring up a lot, because it's very obvious is, is being loud.
Because if you're in a leadership position,
you need to be able to make people hear you.
And some people are born with a very loud voice.
I was luckily born with a very loud voice and it's inherited from my genes,
right? And my kids inherited there. My kids are all can be very loud,
which is sometimes problematic in a house.
But if you can't bark a command so that people can hear you in a machine gun
fight, no, one's me able to do what you asked them to do.
So there's these different characteristics and you can improve upon them.
So if you're not very articulate,
you can read and you can write and you can speak and you become more articulate.
If you are not very good at simplifying problems,
you can start looking at complex problems and thinking about how you can
simplify them and you can get better at that.
The being loud part is there's definitely a genetic aspect of that. So sure.
You can learn to project your voice more, but some people aren't very loud.
They're just born that way. And so what does a person do in that situation?
Well, what a person does in that situation is when they have to give an order,
they tell one of the loud mouths in their platoon to tell everyone to get over
this other building now, and that loud mouth will pass the word.
And so what you do as a leader is you find members for your team that can
compliment your weaknesses.
So there are parts that you can improve and there are parts that you can
improve. And if you,
the only real impediment to improving is someone that doesn't
have the humility to say, you know what?
I think I could work on being more articulate or,
you know what I think I could work on solving problems and making them more
simple, or, you know what, I'm not that loud. And instead of saying,
you know what, that's not a good way to lead. Instead. I say, you know what?
I'm not that loud, but Billy over here is loud.
So I'm going to let him put the word out when it needs to get put out.
But if you're, if you don't have that humility to do that,
you won't improve as a leader.
Have you found those people that even if you lay out what the right, you know,
skills are that they have to work on or where their blind spots are, et cetera,
et cetera, that they just can't,
whether it's ego or whatever else that they just can't,
that you just certain people you just can't get.
Absolutely. It's a, it's a horrible situation to be in. And in the seal teams,
those guys will get fired in the civilian sector. Generally,
those guys get fired because I mean, you, you,
you go into a company and you've got a CEO that is not listening to anyone up or
down the chain of the, not listening to the board,
not listening to the subordinates. How is he going to improve?
He's not going to, and by the way, why does he need to improve?
He needs to improve because his company isn't doing well. So,
but this person might think, Hey, you know, I'm great. I don't,
I'm not gonna learn anything from anybody.
I'm just going to keep doing it my way.
And that guy's not going to stay in that job because they don't have the
humility to say, you know what, I'm probably doing some things wrong.
That's why we're not making money.
And so I need to change some of the things that I'm doing so that we can make
money. But if you don't have that attitude and you're not humble, yeah.
You'll end up getting fired.
So, conversely,
have you seen people that basically had none of the skills that have been able
to overcome it just through perseverance that just innately don't have the
leadership traits that don't have, you know, they don't speak loud.
They aren't clear, they can't make decisions,
but just out of sheer sort of force of will.
There's, there's all these little aspects that you have,
you can improve upon right now. Uh, you're not going to take,
I'm not going to lie to you and say,
you can take somebody that has no aptitude for leadership,
and they're going to turn into a great leader that that's probably not going to
happen, but you can take someone that has minimal aptitude for leadership,
and they can improve the areas where they need to improve.
They can compliment themselves with a team that can cover for the areas where
they're weak and they can end up doing a great job in a leadership position.
For sure. Yeah.
So handing some of this stuff off, people don't think of that in certain ways,
when it comes to leaders,
like they have to do everything or know everything or something,
but actually hand in some of this stuff off is, is good.
Delegating actually is good.
Yeah, absolutely. Like for instance, big shocker.
I don't really like doing paperwork a lot. You know what I mean? Really,
it's kind of, I know it might seem odd,
but I always had guys that worked for me,
I'd figure out that guy that was really good at administrative stuff.
And there you go, guess what?
He's going to do a bunch of administrative stuff and that's great.
And so whatever areas of weakness you have have some, you know,
get a member of your team, recruit someone,
bring someone on board that can actually make these things happen and it'll work
out. Great.
Yeah.
Are you kind of surprised how much we need a leadership sort of in
society right now that we seem to have like a complete dearth of leadership?
I mean,
you mentioned Jordan Peterson before when I see the message that he's bringing
to these people, it's really about getting yourself together, which is the most,
I mean, it's very consistent with your message, but,
but the people that are coming are sort of looking for a leader to say that,
that we just don't have, we seemingly don't have good leaders right now.
Do you think that's a fair estimate?
Well, we do have good leaders.
There's plenty of good leaders out there and I see them all the time in the
business world.
I still work with the military and there's great leaders inside the military.
There's great leaders inside the business world, for sure.
There's also always a lack of leadership. And I mean, I, you know,
on my podcast, I cover,
I cover books about war generally first-person accounts,
and there's a lack of leadership back then and there's good leaders.
So I don't know if it's gotten any better or worse,
but the fact of the matter is that leadership is,
is the hardest thing in the world. As far as I know, it's,
it's the hardest thing. You know, people used to ask me what I,
when I first got out of the military, what was the most complex, you know,
operation that you would plan on with planning operations?
Isn't that big of a deal? Like here's a bad guy. Here's the assets that we have.
Here's what we're going to do to go take them out. I mean,
this is stuff that generally it's, it's not that hard to do,
but the hard part is, is leading human beings.
And so why does it seem like there's that we need better leadership because you
always need better leadership.
And because leadership is so hard to actually do properly. Yeah.
Do you think we need some sort of mandatory military service to get some of this
through to young people?
I think military service is great for people. I know it was,
it was great for me and it, it worked out really well for me,
but I really don't believe in,
in mandatory service because I really don't believe that it's good
for government to tell people what you need to do. Yeah.
I don't really support that,
but I definitely support and encourage everyone to go in the reserves, you know,
go join that, join the army or the Marine Corps, the Navy air force reserves,
where you go away for six weeks or eight weeks and you kind of learn what the
military is about.
And then you do one weekend a month and two weeks in the summertime for,
you know, indefinitely.
So I think I have a pretty good handle on your politics. But do,
do you even have a label that kind of works for you politically?
Uh, I don't know. You, you, I don't know. I don't know what to label.
I don't know. I think it'd be pretty hard to label it.
Sort of summing up sort of your political beliefs. What would you say?
I think that, I guess a broad statement would be,
I don't think that the government is the solution to our problems, but yeah,
I think that generally unleashing individuals to try and make things happen is
the best way for things to work. It's,
it's consistent with decentralized command that to talk,
talk about in the first book that I wrote with my, my brother life is
you can't control everything. You know,
centralized decision-making does not work. It doesn't work on the battlefield.
It doesn't work in business. It doesn't work with governments. So that's,
you know, broadly speaking guy,
I don't think that the government should control what individuals are doing as,
as little as possible. Do there have to be some rules and regulations in place?
Absolutely. But the framework should be as loose as possible.
Just like if I'm running a seal platoon, it's not every man for himself. It's,
here's our standard operating procedures.
Here's the areas where we commit to disciplined process.
But then once you understand those and you know,
those you're allowed to operate freely within those guidelines to execute the
mission. And that's what works. That's what makes, not just the seal teams.
That's what makes any good military unit good.
And that's what makes good businesses good, good businesses.
Aren't good because someone is micromanaging. Every single decision,
good businesses are good because people broadly understand the direction they're
heading.
They understand that and they're allowed to move forward as they see fit.
You shocked when you say something like that,
which obviously I agree with a hundred percent. I mean,
all I talk about here is personal responsibility over and over that that doesn't
seem to sort of be the kind of flavor of the day at the moment that this,
if you listen to mainstream media, it's sort of more, well,
the government should give you this and we should take from some give to others.
That there's a more feeling of you,
you were owed something rather than you got to get something you're asking if
I'm surprised by that. Yeah. Because then, because the way you're laying it out,
it's obvious. You know what I mean? Like, I mean that in the best sense,
it's obvious, like, yeah, it's your life go,
go do something that has value and create.
I guess the real easy answer is no, I'm not surprised by it at all.
Because if I come here and offer you something for free,
why would you not want it? Why would you not want to take it? If I say, Hey,
you can have this house for free. And you'd say, okay,
that seems like a good deal to me. Right. And so, yeah, sure.
I understand why people think that sounds like a good idea because it's
something for free and they want to do in their own individual world,
they think, okay,
I do want to take advantage of this and get something for free.
So it doesn't surprise me at all.
That what is unfortunate is if you can't draw the line between, Hey,
everyone gets everything for free and there's a price to that,
that somebody is gonna have to pay. That's where it becomes.
There is some costs in, in there somewhere, somewhere. Yeah.
So tell me what it was like when you started writing.
Cause that must've been a whole other ball of wax.
You know, it was, I was actually an English major in college and I, I went,
I went to college halfway through my Navy career.
I started off as an enlisted guy, went,
went to college and then I became an officer and then went to college
eventually. So,
and the reason I was an English major was because believe it or not,
when you're an officer in the military and actually almost any job in the
military, you have to write, why not have to write? You have to read,
you have to understand because you have to write concept of operations documents
that are going to be pushed up the chain of command.
And they're going to read through them and ask questions and,
and look at the document and try and comprehend what it is that you're trying to
do. You got to write evaluations for your troops and your,
your troops are getting promoted based on the evaluations that you write.
Same with awards. You got to write awards,
same thing with after actions reports. So if you do an operation and things,
don't go, well,
you have to be able to articulate and explain that what happened and then pass
that word on. So everyone understands not only that you're being,
you're being given direction, verbal direction. Yes, of course.
But you're given written direction as well.
You're given missions in a written format or you're given rules of engagement in
a written format written by lawyers.
And I realized while I was a young enlisted guy and then as a junior officer,
what I really need to be able to do is understand and communicate
well up and down the chain of command. So when I went to college, I said, yeah,
I want to learn English. I want to get good at it. And so that's what I did.
And so obviously I did a bunch of writing and a ton of reading when I was in,
when I was an English major in college.
And then when I was in the military is writing, you're writing all the time.
And then when, when, when I got out,
when I was working with these companies and, and it grew really quickly,
and that's why my, my buddy,
who was one of the platoon commanders that worked for me in the battle of
Ramadi, Leif, Babin, he, he was getting out of the Navy too. And,
you know, as we started, I started to need some cover. And I said, Hey, man,
you wanna want to jump in and get some of this? And he was all on board.
And then as we started doing this, people would always say, Hey,
do you have this stuff written down anywhere?
Do you have a document you can give us? And so we eventually wrote it down.
And then that's how the, that's how the first book came. Yeah.
Can you lay out a little bit about the battle of Ramadi? You basically,
you sort of wrote the plans.
The person that led the battle of Ramadi that I was in was a guy named, uh,
Sean McFarland, who was a Colonel at the time, he retired as a general,
just a super smart,
incredibly competent and great leader. He's a great leader.
And he came in with, so I had 40 seals with me, right?
I had 40 sales with me and 60 support people.
Colonel McFarland had 5,600 man armored brigade that we
supported and we helped them. We worked together in the battle of Ramadi,
vicious, fighting, very tough battle,
and really took a city that was completely controlled by the insurgence in
2005, 2006. And by early 2007,
it was almost completely pacified. So it was, it was incredible.
It was incredible,
incredible turnaround and an incredible Testament to the
capability of the us armed forces.
Do you guys pay any attention to what's going on politically back home when
you're halfway across the world?
Yes, absolutely.
You have to pay attention to what's going on politically back home if it,
especially like at this time when we deployed to Ramadi, so it's 2005, 2006,
this is smack dab in the middle of the rising
negative public opinion about the war in Iraq.
It's also where we had our own government officials here in America that were
saying, this is unwinnable. This is another Vietnam. This is a quagmire.
We shouldn't be there to bring everyone home. So yeah, you,
you absolutely hear those things and that's not good. That's not,
it's not a positive thing.
It's not a positive thing to have your own government officials in America
saying that you cannot win. And meanwhile, you're going out on an operation.
Does that.
Drive you guys crazy more than anything else?
Sort of the political elite that often have no idea what's happening on the
ground that are just spouting off stuff.
For sure. For sure. Yeah. But as I said, it's you listened to it,
but you can only pay so much attention to it.
There's so much other things to focus on. I mean,
you think about it a little bit,
but you're not caught up in the 24 hour news cycle. Like, you know,
like people can tend to do here in America because you're working and
you're getting back from one operation. You're preparing for another operation.
I've got guys in the field, I got another element in the field.
I'm going in the field. It's you don't have time to be sitting around, Hey,
I wonder what this politician is saying about what we're doing.
Of leadership that you brought to.
It was just about managing stress for your guys.
Just making sure that they were actually okay in the midst of the chaos.
Y absolutely. You have to do some of that. I mean, it's, it's a,
it's a balancing act between all kinds.
There's all kinds of things that you're trying to juggle at the same time and
managing stress on the guys is definitely one of them.
And in a situation where you're getting guys wounded and your guys are getting
killed, that stress meter can get pegged out pretty quick.
So you have to manage it. You have to do it to the best of your ability. That's,
it's, it's hard. It's hard to because
the war is going to keep going and you are going to keep you,
you have work that needs to continue.
So the stress is going to build up on,
on the troops and it's different for every guy, you know, the,
the frontline seal or soldier or Marine they're,
they're worried about getting blown up.
They're worried about getting shot and killed.
They're worried about their friends getting shot and killed.
They're worried about their friends getting blown up when you're in charge of a
bunch of guys, you're,
you're worried about all those guys and that happening to them.
You're worried about if we make a mistake, if we do something wrong,
if we cause some massive collateral damage that has a negative,
strategic impact, like that's, you have all of those stresses and you know,
to control stress, what do you do? That's like,
you look at the things you can't control, the things you can't control,
the you focus on the things you can control and the things that you can't
control, you do your best to mitigate, and then you don't worry about them.
Cause they'll drive you crazy.
W what do you make of sort of where we're at now,
having lived through the Iraq war? Like, was it the right thing to do?
Should we have done things differently?
Should we have not just announced we were leaving one day, the whole,
the whole thing.
The whole thing is that hindsight is 2020 and any normal human being
can look back at the American history as a whole and find out all
the mistakes that we've made, which are, you know, infinite, right.
We make an infinite number of mistakes,
and we do the best to try and repair those once they've taken place. The,
so for me to look at it from that angle, it's like, okay, yeah,
there's all kinds of mistakes we make as a country.
And we have make as a country and we will make as a country,
but the best way for me to kind of rationalize or not even rationalize,
because I don't think it needs rationalizations. But I,
when I look at it from a granular level, which is,
which is very straightforward, we went into a city,
the city of Ramadi that was being controlled by
sick insurgents,
the most sadistic evil sub-human
people that you can imagine. They were raping, torturing,
skinning people, alive, murdering whole families, beheading people.
And when we went in there, and again,
I'm not talking about we as this small group of seals,
I'm talking about when this massive force of us coalition and
Iraqi forces went into that city and liberated those people
from the torturous and sadistic
control of those insurgents,
the people of Vermont were overjoyed.
And they would cheer when we killed insurgents.
And they would tell us where insurgents were,
and it was a beautiful transition to watch.
And it didn't really take place until after we left.
But after we left and we saw this, it was peaceful. It was literally peaceful.
It went from a complete war zone to a,
to a peaceful city and where they were,
they had markets open the street again, they had kids going to school,
they had girls schools. Now, you know, there,
there wasn't in the city of Ramadi, there was schools for girls.
And this was just unheard of while the insurgents where they're trying to,
you know, uh,
punish the populous with their psychotic brand
of, of Al-Qaeda Islam. Right. And, and the,
the people from ADI did not want that at all.
And so from that perspective, it's like, I go to sleep every night.
Yeah.